I would now like to calculate
the moment of inertia
of a uniform sphere.
And it has a mass
m and radius r.
I'm going to look at three axes.
So I'll call this the x-axis,
the y-axis, and the z-axis.
And first, let's calculate
the moment about the z-axis.
So if I write down
our definition,
and I'm going to calculate
it about the center of mass,
so the moment about the z-axis.
How do we do that?
Well, we take a mass element,
and have to be a little bit
careful here.
Because if you
think about what is
our [? perp ?] for
this mass element,
it's actually x squared
plus y squared, squared.
So the distance here, because
it's going in a circle,
the radius of that circle
is x squared plus y squared.
So we have x squared
plus y squared,
and we're integrating
over the sphere.
Now, this looks like
a tough integral.
But let's now look at what
would the moment of inertia
be about the x-axis?
Well, the only difference here
is I'm integrating now, first,
if it's rotating
about this axis,
and I had my mass
element, instead
of x squared plus y
squared about the z-axis,
it's y squared plus z
squared about the x-axis.
That's the
perpendicular distance.
And if I calculate the moment
of inertia about the y-axis,
then same argument-- I have
z squared plus x squared.
Now, the beauty
of this problem--
and in physics, when
we talk about beauty,
we often talk
about symmetry-- is
that by the symmetry of the
sphere, all of these moments
are equal.
And let's call that I cm.
Now, if I add these three
pieces together, what do I get?
So if I add I cm z plus
I cm x plus I cm y,
I get 3 times the moment
about the center of the axes.
So what happens when I
add these three integrals?
I get dm.
If you'll notice, x
squared appears twice,
y squared appears twice,
and z squared appears twice.
So we get 2 times x squared
plus y squared plus z squared.
But x squared plus y
squared plus z squared
is the radius of a small
sphere of thickness dr.
And my mass element-- now I have
to integrate over the sphere.
And so now our mass element,
dm, is the volume density
of this times the volume.
Now what is the volume density?
Well, that's the total
mass over 4/3 pi r cubed.
And what is the
volume of a sphere
of radius r and thickness dr?
That's 4 pi r squared dr.
So if I put that into
my expression, what
I get-- let's just
get rid of the 4
pi's, and I get 3m over r
cubed times r squared dr.
And so our 3 I cm, I
have a factor of 2,
this integral becomes 2
times dm times r squared.
And the dm is 3m r
cubed r squares dr times
another r squared.
And what are we integrating
over are r variable from?
These spherical shells that
we're integrating outward
go from r equal 0 to
r equal capital R.
Notice that our 3 m's cancel.
And we'll just
write this is I cm
equals factor 2 times m over r
cubed times the integral of r
to the fourth dr from zero to
R. And that's a simple integral
to do.
r to the fourth is r to
the fifth divided by 5.
And so we get 2 over 5 m R
to the fifth over R cubed.
And we conclude that
the moment of inertia
about any of the axes of the
sphere is 2/5 m R squared.
And in this calculation,
it's a beautiful example
of how we use the symmetry
of the sphere to simplify
very complicated integrals.